A ver, estoy grabando esta. Sí, sí, sí.
Vale, vale. Nos quedamos el otro día en
en etiquetar, ¿vale? Todo el todo el
tema de el etiquetado de los cables
super importante, de verdad,
super importante tanto para nosotros
como para los compañeros que vengan
detrás.
el el mantener una, o sea, vamos, una
disciplina así con esto, ¿no?
Es muy importante,
¿vale? Eh, vale, sigue etiquetado
cables. Nos quedamos aquí el otro día.
Vale, vale. Cableado, estructurado y
certificado.
Vale, pues eso, lo que os decía, ¿vale?
Que los cambios que se realizan en las
instalaciones de red, especialmente en
en su cableado, son frecuentes debido a
la evolución de los equipos y a las
necesidades de los usuarios. Esto nos
lleva a tener otro eh a tener en cuenta
un factor importante como es la
flexibilidad.
Ah, no, la flexibilidad del cable, sí,
sino ya veréis.
Vale. Estructuración del cable. Un
sistema de cableado bien diseñado debe
tener menos estas dos cualidades,
seguridad y flexibilidad. A esos
parámetros, a estos parámetros se le
puede añadir otros menos exigentes desde
el punto de vista del diseño de red,
como son el coste económico, la
facilidad de instalación, etcétera.
La estructuración del cable se consigue
construyendo módulos independientes que
se enventen la red completa en sus
sistemas de redependientes,
pero integrados, de forma que un
subsistema queda limitado por el
siguiente subsistema.
Estos subsistemas siguen una
organización jerarquizada por niveles
desde el sistema principal hasta el
último de los subsistemas. ¿A qué os
recuerda esto de de en topologías de de
red, por ejemplo?
como que en eh topologías, en los tipos
de
Sí, ¿te acuerdas las los tipos de de
eh cómo es? De despliegue de una red que
estaba en
No me acuerdo de todas, o sea, me
acuerdo de la de bus, la
estrellada. estrellada. Correcto.
La que es completa, que no sé cómo se se
llama, que están todos conectados.
Y esta sería, por ejemplo, nos está
hablando de algo de eficiencia con la de
árbol, ¿vale? Que está así jerarquizada.
Ah, vale. Sí,
vale. Entonces sí que nos est no se
estaría realmente hablando de eso. O
sea, si abrimos,
¿habéis estoqueteado para que para que
trace estos días con con ejercicios? Sí,
habéis enviado cosas, ¿verdad?
¿Qué?
Que habéis enviado cosas, ¿verdad? Al
al Drive. A ver,
estaría redes locales, entregas no
evaluables.
Abraham y Ramón, poneos las pilas que no
habéis enviado nada de
de ejercicios con el paquet traser. Esto
lo vamos a tocar bastante.
Eca,
lo mío sale.
Sí, sí, lo tuyo está. Sí, sí, Jorge.
Vale, vale.
Está lo de Eduardo que no. A ver, Edúo
es que tuvo
Es que lo que no me aclaro es por dónde
se envía todo eso.
¿Cómo? ¿Cómo
que no me aclaro por dónde mandarlo? Te
lo mando por correo, por
A ver, abrí un drive en el que, o sea,
tú tienes el enlace realmente y tienes
permiso de edición. Entonces, tú abres
Drive y tú tienes un permiso de edición
en esa carpeta. Tú puedes ahí dejar lo
que quieras.
Pero, ¿en qué link? O sea, es que
sí que os lo envíé. No, no, no os llega
un link a vuestro correo.
Un link de
Sí, a mí sí.
Sí, es un link en el que te debe de
poner algo así como eh pues a ver porque
creé una cuenta, ¿vale?, que se llama
fjaviermr@gmail.com.
FJVersm
vía Google Drive. Vale, esto no,
eso es. Sí. Entonces ahí,
vale. Es que como Google como el de esto
no me avisa ni me entero de
Vale, igual yo se lo dije en clase, pero
igual hombre igual en ese momento
sí, pero se me acaba pasando,
¿no? Que sí, que sí, que no, no pasa
nada. Bueno, que eso que lo sepáis,
¿vale? Que está yo creé una carpeta
general, ¿vale? Sin perm con en la que
solo tengo yo edición. Luego
subcarpetas. Para cada para cada
asignatura hay una carpeta en la que
tampoco tenéis permiso de edición, pero
luego sí que hay una que es entregas no
evaluables,
que o bien las entregas se pueden hacer
o aquí o en la plataforma de Tame,
¿vale? en cualquiera de los dos sitios
es válido. Eh, habrá ejercicios que a lo
mejor no tengan no tengan el carácter
de, o sea, el botoncito de entrega en la
plataforma de Tame. Entonces, los
enviáis por aquí. Si están en la
plataforma de Tame, pues oye, lo envías
por allí y ya está.
A ver, pero más que nada, a ver, más que
nada estos no son evaluables, ¿vale? Ya,
ya pondremos evaluables de estos. Esto
es para que os vayáis cogiendo al al
packet tracer porque lo vamos lo vamos a
utilizar bastante en esta asignatura
y cuando digo bastante es bastante
que al es que bueno, disculpar el
un taco, al final es que es eh
a ver, no hay es que no tenemos tampoco
otras maneras de simular ciertas
condiciones.
Para que tracer es un una herramienta
estupenda para eso.
El otro día estuvimos haciendo una
práctica con segundo, por ejemplo, que
era un era un servidor de HCP,
eh, era un servidor de NS, un servidor
de No sé si os suena. Me imagino que sí,
¿vale? porque sí que sí que entendé, o
sea, sí que sí que tenéis bastante
conocimiento de todo esto.
Era un servidor de servidor de NS,
un servidor de HCP y un servidor web,
¿vale? Entonces, al final con Packet
Tracer tú puedes crear incluso una
paginita web y lo ves desde un desde un
equipo cliente que te ha pasado a través
del servidor porque tiene un alojamiento
web. Bueno, es que es se puede hacer
virguerías, eh, con esto
y realmente es que te simula las
condiciones que que vas a tener en
cuando lo hagas en físico. Tanto los de
presencial como vosotros lo lo
utilizan esto
tras la manera de aprender también el
tema de redes.
Vale, luego vemos, ¿vale?, los
ejercicios estos que que habéis enviado.
Vale, podemos, a ver, la estructuración
del cable se consigue construyendo,
bueno, lo que estábamos diciendo,
¿vale?, que sería algo así parecido a
una topología en árbol o jerárquica.
Bueno, podemos concluir que el cableoado
estructurado es una técnica que permite
cambiar, identificar, mover periféricos
o equipos de una red con flexibilidad y
sencillez. Según esta definición, una
solución de cable estructurado debe
tener dos características: modularidad,
que sirve para construir arquitecturas
de red de en mayor tamaño sin
incrementar la complejidad.
Y o claro, imaginad que desplegáis algo
muy tocho para, no sé, para un montón de
dispositivos. No es mejor hacerlo
acotado por módulos, o sea, o por zonas
que hacer todo el despliegue entero por
si luego ese despliegue lo tenéis que
cambiar.
Si ese despliegue tenéis que cambiarlo y
lo habéis hecho todo de una o todo, eh,
o sea, estamos hablando de conceptos,
¿vale? bastante bastante generalistas.
Imaginad, no sé, 100 puestos que los
haces todos de una y no los modulas, no
los
no hace no creas subredes. Por ejemplo,
tú si creas una subred 10 15 equipos, no
tienen por qué ser eh clientes, o sea,
no tienen por qué ser PCs, por ejemplo,
pueden ser impresoras, puede ser de
todo, ¿vale? a cualquier dispositivo
conectado. Si creas esas subredes y
dentro de esas subredes, otras subredes,
o sea, 15, 20, 20 equipos, algo así, es
más fácil
eh modificar modificar de esta manera
que si que no si haces un global de
todo.
No sé si me explico.
modularidad que sirve para construir
arquitectura, en definitiva, eso,
modularidad, ¿vale? Que sirve para
construir arquitecturas de red de mayor
tamaño e incrementar la complejidad del
sistema y flexibilidad que permite el
crecimiento no traumático de la red.
Vale, aquí tendríamos a ver que nos
sus sistemas horizontales.
Vale. ¿En qué contesto esto?
Vale, sí, esto nos podría servir.
Esto nos podría servir perfectamente.
Imaginad que tenemos dos plantas, ¿vale?
Una con x clientes y otra también.
Eh, diferenciarlo a lo mejor. O sea,
imaginad que podía aquí qué dos opciones
tendríamos
a la hora de
de llevar esto a cabo. O sea, que lo
plantearíais así, así está separado y yo
lo veo óptimo. ¿Vale? Pero, ¿qué otra
opción podríamos hacer? Podíamos
un cable, por ejemplo, de aquí que
viniese a estos, subiese y enganchase
con estos. ¿Vale? que te ahí que
tendríamos un problema, por ejemplo,
ante un
ante una rotura, ante yo que sé,
cualquier
hm cualquier inconveniente, ¿vale? Nos
vuelca la, o sea, nos cierra la red
entera.
Así de esta manera lo tenemos
tenemos separado en dos en dos grupos
como ser sus sistemas horizontales, sus
sistemas llaman aquí, ¿vale?
Lo tendríamos separado en dos y que las
cosas que ocurren aquí, ¿no?, o sea, los
errores, los fallos, las roturas, la lo
que sea, las incidencias, que no me sale
la palabra, las incidencias que aquí
ocurran no os afectan aquí
y viceversa.
Vale, esto es un sistema óptimo de crear
una una red.
Este, a ver, ¿por qué está aquí abajo?
Vale, sería una
Sí, esto sería como una implementación
de, o sea, con más detalle, ¿no? Este de
aquí, una planta y otra planta. Aquí
esto se supone que es un el cuatro
cuarto de comunicaciones o distribuidor
de planta. Vale. Sí, sí, se sería esto
más detalle, ¿eh? En cada planta tenemos
tenemos lo mismo, se supone, ¿vale?
Sería distribuidor, distribuye la la red
tanto de telefonía como de
como de datos. Vale.
Vale. Partiendo del subsistema de más
bajo nivel jerárquico, tenemos la
siguiente organización. Localización de
cada puesto de trabajo. A cada puesto
deben poder llegar todos los posibles
medios de transmisión de la señal que
requiera cada equipamiento.
UTP, STP, fibra óptica, cables para el
uso de transportes.
Subsistema horizontal de planta. Es
recomendable la instalación de una
canaleta o un o un subsuelo por el que
llevarlo. Si, el otro día creo que
hablábamos de llevarlo por el por el
suelo, ¿verdad? en salas muy grandes,
diáfanas,
en que las canalizaciones sí que sí que
podían ir registradas
por canaletas por el por el suelo,
suelos que estén que estén pensados para
ello.
Vale.
Las exigencias de ancho de banda pueden
requerir el uso de dispositivos sociales
para comunicar
paquetes de red o concentrar y repartir
el cableado en estrella.
Su sistema concentrar, vale, recomend
Sí, sí, esto sería un sistema. Sí,
realmente partiría de aquí si lo
analizamos sí que sería así,
sería en estrella, o sea, cada ramal nos
va uno. Esto es lo que han lo que han
dibujado ellos. Luego podríamos hacer
una una topología diferente,
¿vale?
sistema distribuidor. Aquí podemos
incluir los racks,
los distribuidores de red con sus
latiguillos. ¿Sabes lo que es un rack?
No,
lo estuvimos hablando el otro día,
¿eh?
Vale, espera. No, no, no te preocupes.
Esto no es
esto
Pero, ¿por qué cojo esta? Vale,
aquí. Esto
vale, esto sería un rack, un armario
donde tenía habíamos eh esto es un rack
también, o sea, digamos que es como la
caja del del PC doméstico, pero para
servidores.
Lo que pasa que son cajas pues eso,
tochas de
180 y tantos,
un 1,0,
sí, 1,6, 17.
las más altas y eh las pequeñas también
las habréis visto en muchos sitios.
Y luego las unidades se medían en
lo estuvimos mirando el otro día también
que eran urc
No, espera,
espera.
Vale, que la la unidad de medida está.
Sí, realmente,
o sea, esto al final lo que
lo que hace es que no vayas a visitar
páginas. Al final
la gente dejará de de escribir artículos
y dejará de escribir cosas porque no
porque no tiene tráfico. De hecho, está
ocurriendo ya.
Al final buscas algo, o sea, esto es lo
que os decía, ¿vale? La unidad R1,
¿vale? Pues me salía, ¿vale? U o Ru,
que son unidades de RAC, que son medias
estandarizadas,
¿vale? dentro del RAC y los componentes
van en función de esas medidas,
los componentes que instalas dentro del
RAC.
Lo que os decía, o sea, a ver, tú
generas una pregunta, ¿vale? Y aquí te
lo contesta ya directamente la IA del la
IA de turno, texto generado con IA.
Vale, ¿qué haces? ya no vas a ninguna
página a buscarlo específicamente.
Vale, al final, ¿qué pasa si nadie
genera contenido? Si la gente ya no
tiene tráfico. De hecho, es que se es
que lo leí el otro día porque se estaba
se estaba ya había un murmullo ya de
quejas a nivel de eso de gente que había
que había visto como bajaba
brutalmente el el tráfico en sus en sus
webs,
¿vale? Porque esto al final, ¿dónde se
retroalimenta?
La se está retroalimentando del
contenido que se ha ido generando
durante
mucho tiempo, que vale que mucha gente
copiaba a otros, pero pero claro,
algunos no.
Bueno, en fin, eso
reflexión,
¿vale? Subsistema vertical o backb. Este
subsistema está encargado de comunicar
todos los subsistemas horizontales, por
lo que requieren medios de transmisión
de señal con un ancho de banda elevado y
de elevada protección.
Los backbons más modernos se construyen
con tecnología ATM, redes FDTDI o
Gigabyte Ethernet. Este tipo de
comunicaciones,
¿sabéis la
qué significa Gigabyternet?
Vale, pues es un cable de alta, lo
veremos en cuando toquemos el tema de
cables.
Es un cable de alta velocidad de de
fibra,
¿vale? Para para comunicación por por
internet.
Este tipo de comunicaciones es ideal
para su uso de instalaciones que
requieran de aplicaciones multimedia.
Su sistema de campus extiende la red de
área local al entorno de varios
edificios. Por lo tanto, en cuanto a su
extensión se parece a una red man.
¿Os acordáis que lo estuvimos viendo al
principio de de todo de todos los
temarios que estaban la WAN, la MAN y la
GAN?
Pero mantiene toda la funcionalidad de
una red de área leocal en medio de
transmisión utilizando con mayor
frecuencia la fibra óptica con topología
de doble anillo.
Vale, esto sería doble anillo.
a la estrella, que es la que todos
recordamos, pero aquí faltaría de punto
a punto
y la jerárquica que hablábamos antes
sería esta de árbol.
¿Queréis que os lo pase esta esta imagen
que creo que no aparece por el temario?
Os la paso aquí por el chat.
A ver,
ahí está,
ahí está. No, espera que le de a enviar.
Vale, ahora sí.
Vale,
cuartos de entrada de subsistema de
campus. Vale, estamos ahí. Cuartos de
entrada de servicios,
telecomunicaciones, equipos. Son los
lugares apropiados para recoger la
entrada de los servicios externos para
la organización, líneas telefónicas,
acceso internet, recepción de del por
cable o satélite,
instalación de la maquinaria de
comunicaciones y para los equipamientos
informáticos centralizados. En algunas
organizaciones
existen los tres tipos de espacios.
En otras, el cuarto de equipos incluye
el de telecomunicaciones y el de entrada
de servicio sustituido. ¿Habéis estado
en alguno en alguna sala dedicada
dedicada a esto?
No,
vale, pues ya está, ya entrarás,
ya entrarás.
Vale, está clasificado, ¿no? O sea, lo
digo porque al final se te van los ojos
allí para dices, ostras, esto es esto,
esto es lo otro.
Vale, que una cosa es la teoría de verlo
de de tal y otra el el ver ahí todo
junto
y en funcionamiento.
Vale, esta clasificación jerarquía del
subsistema de cableado estructural no es
inflexible. Incluso las denominaciones
de cada subsistema pueden variar de unos
textos técnicos a otros. A la hora de
diseñar una instalación, lo importante
es estructurar los subsistemas para
poder documentarlos correctamente y
facilitar las ampliaciones o
modificaciones de cualquier elemento del
cableado.
¿Vale? Si queréis e
miramos un poco los ejercicios,
¿vale? Pongo hasta aquí.
Esto aquí 29
del 2025.
Vale.
He.
¿Quieres que veamos este Jorge los los
ejercicios que ha subido?
Eh, por mí bien.
Vale,
espero que estén bien, pero bueno, por
mí,
¿no? Bueno, hombre, no. Y si no están
bien, no pasa nada tampoco. Yo creo que
sí que estarán bien.
A ver, subiste
a los ha subido en un rar. Vale, genial.
Vale, luego tenemos de Edu, pero como no
como no está porque porque él se
conectará cuando pueda, está trabajando
y eso,
eh, a ver, tienes aquí un uno de texto.
Ah, vale, porque es el que os lo envié.
Pero no lo tienes contestado este, ¿no?
[Música]
¿Cuál? ¿Cuál?
A ver, has enviado uno que es eh Vale,
ejercicio 1.1, ejercicio 1.2. Vale, voy
a descargarlos a la carpeta y los veo y
les echamos un ojo.
A ver si está vacío. Quizá he subido.
Sí, no, pero no te preocupes, no pasa
nada.
A ver,
a ver.
Vale, lo he descargado.
A ver, descarga. ¿Dónde está esto?
Esto sería redes, ejercicios.
Esto sería, vale, este sería el
ejercicio.
Ese es un ejercicio que os puse,
pero eso no es evaluable, ¿verdad?
Vale, extraer todo aquí.
Vale, tenemos el 1.1.
Vale, que habías puesto,
¿no? Pero yo no quería, no decía este,
o sea, no es que no no es que lo hayas
hecho más ni nada eso, no que que yo
quería abrirlos de Paquet Tráer, quiero
decir.
A ver, ejercicio uno
sería así. Este era bastante sencillito,
¿verdad? Que creo que era poner un
más que nada por familiar
de de Cisco también están puestos ahí.
Sí, sí, sí. Es lo que son es lo que
estaba abriendo ahora. Están dentro del
RAR, ¿verdad?
Eh, sí,
hay dos PDFs y dos
y
sí tienes tres tres de Packet Tracer,
sí,
y luego dos de PDF, pero no la idea no
era sacar el de PDF ahora.
A ver.
Si me deja. Vale, con este.
A ver, yo creo que lo hice con esta
cuenta.
Espero que sí. Sí, era esta.
Vale. Packet tracer aquí.
Vale. ¿Y qué nos pedía?
nos pedía conectar
en el Hubat
PCs
y luego había que ponerles la IP,
¿verdad? Cierto. Es es así.
Sí, así
es que no recuerdo ahora. Claro. Y
entonces tenías que mirar
1.2
1.3
1.4. Veremos que esto, o sea, no hay que
hacerlo manual, que aquí se puede se
puede implementar un servidor, es eh lo
veremos posiblemente al final de
Creo que está es que creo que está en el
temario segundo, pero bueno, o sea, es
tan sencillo como implementarlo
en el hubo vale, sería en un servidor
o en un router, también lo podemos poner
en un router, que sería asignarle una,
o sea, las la la las IPs a los
diferentes dispositivos que se conectan
al en esta red, asignárselo de forma
dinámica. Quiero decir que no tendríais
que ir poniendo uno por uno sus
diferentes IPs. Básicamente lo que os
ocurre cuando os conectáis con un
portátil, cuando cuando vienes Jorge y
te conectas con el portátil al al a
Tame, por ejemplo, o me conecto yo con
el portátil allí en Tame. Tamos, o sea,
el servidor de Tamel o el router es el
servidor en este caso, lo que nos lo que
nos,
o sea, nos nos matricula con una IP, con
un número,
o sea, IP sería esto de aquí, hombre.
Imaginos lo sabéis, pero
que lo sabéis todos.
Esto sería la IP, la dirección que
nosotros hemos asignado de forma manual,
pero si nosotros activamos el DHCP
ya no ya no lo tendríamos de forma
manual,
¿vale? Entonces esta eh ahí lo
tendríamos de forma dinámica y nos lo
asignaría el servidor, o sea, en este
caso no, porque no tiene no tiene las
propiedades de asignar de asignar las
IP, sería el servidor o el router,
¿vale? lo que nosotros tengamos
configurado y le podemos decir, créame h
tantas direcciones IPs como yo te diga
de la de la 192168.1.20
a la 192.168.1.75
y luego le dices y exclúyeme de asignar
direcciones, eh,
o sea, excluye de asignar esta este esta
serie de direcciones. Por ejemplo,
podemos decir la que habíamos dicho la
20 a la 75, pues le podemos decir la 50
a la 55 y la 58 no me la asignes a
nadie, que esa la voy a asignar yo de
forma dinámica, o sea, o no las quiero
asignar por lo que sea,
¿vale? Podemos crear exclusiones
dentro de dentro del ámbito que creamos
para en el servidor para
para las direcciones IPs.
¿Esto por qué venía? Ah, vale, porque
estábamos hablando de la IP. En este
caso, a ver, es un ejercicio muy
sencillito y es estático, o sea, lo
ponemos estático y luego vemos que est
esto es lo que estuvimos mirando el otro
día,
el tema de eh de mandar un mandamos, por
ejemplo, de aquí que como o sea, si lo
hacíamos os creo que lo hice con Sí, lo
lo haría con vosotros esto, o sea, no
teníamos asignada ninguna dirección IP a
nadie y hicimos esto y no salió no salió
exitoso, puso un fallo ahí enorme. ¿Por
qué? Porque ningún cliente tenía su
dirección IP.
Entonces es como llamar, como llamar con
un teléfono a ningún teléfono.
O sea, tú no puedes llamar a ningún
teléfono porque no te va, o sea, marcas
marcas cero, por ejemplo. ¿A quién
llamas marcando cero? Si nadie tiene esa
dirección,
¿vale? Es que es que no sería ni eso, o
sea, no puedes ni marcar nada porque
realmente no puedes enviar nada. ¿Vale?
Entonces, a ver cómo
qué es lo que hace.
Mm, imagina que le quitamos.
Bueno, vamos a ver primero lo que hace
cuando, que esto ya lo verías tú, Jorge,
cuando lo hiciste.
Bien.
Vale, entonces
vale, vemos que el sobre llega y ahora
lo envía a todo el mundo,
¿vale? Y solo el que
solo al que le habíamos dicho que lo
reciba es el que contesta luego y ahora
lo vuelve a enviar.
a todo el mundo otra vez,
¿vale? Y solo lo recibe al que le
habíamos dicho, o sea, lo reciben todos,
¿vale? Pero todos estos dicen, "No, no,
que esto no es para mí." Y este dice,
"P04", dice, "Esto tampoco es para mí."
Y PC01 dice, "Sí, sí, esto es mío."
Vale, esa es la A ver, esto creo que os
lo os lo estuvimos mirando, ¿no? También
la diferencia entre hub y y
estos y los switch.
Switch era un dispositivo inteligente
que que te encaminaba lo el lo que tú
querías enviar te lo encaminaba a donde
tú querías enviar y no te llenaba la red
de paquetes como si.
Vale, cosa muy distinta es, vale, ahora
quitamos esta
dos clics, lo quitamos.
Ahora a este
lo ponemos en DHP
y no va a recibir recibirá
no tiene nada. No, no recibe nada
realmente.
Y este CCP lo ponemos también en
Ay, es que estoy en modo simulación.
Digo, ¿por qué me salen aquí ahora
los sobrecitos estos los paquetes? Vale,
entonces aquí no vale dep lo que recibe
es una dirección a pipa,
¿vale? que es la la que nos pone
las que la que nos lo que se nos asigna
cuando no tenemos una una dirección
y ve ni estática ni dinámica.
Vale, ahora cogemos y enviamos de aquí a
este.
Vale, como sí que tenemos
lo que yo quería no era esto,
esto, esto. Aquí nos falla, ¿vale? Aquí
sí que nos falla. entre estos dos
sí que no funciona porque está estarían
digamos en el mismo rango, ¿vale? que es
una dirección, pues eso, a pipa que se
llama es que se llama así
cuando tratamos de hacer esa mismo entre
una dirección IP establecida manualmente
o dinámicamente, en este caso sería
sería manual,
falla. ¿Por qué? porque entiende que no
están en la misma red,
¿vale? Aunque sí que tengamos una
dirección, es un poco más más
complejo, pero pero sí sería algo así.
Vale, que
a ver, vamos a quitar esto y vamos a ver
lo que ocurre.
A recordar que hemos hecho de una
dirección, de esta dirección, sin
dirección
a esta dirección con con dirección,
no es que no tenga dirección realmente,
es que veremos el concepto, ¿vale? Lo
veremos en los
que yo creo que no hemos llegado a eso.
Sí, lo sé que lo estuve viendo en un
segundo.
¿Os suena eso? La pipa. Es que creo que
que con vosotros no hemos llegado a eso.
No,
no. Vale, no lo veremos, lo veremos.
Lo digo, a ver, lo digo por no llenar de
conceptos aquí esto a lo bestia tampoco,
porque se entiendo que es mucho
cuando entremos de lleno en redes, en
direcciones IP y todo eso, ya nos
aparecerá.
Vale, aquí vamos a hacer la simulación.
¿Y qué nos hace?
que ha fallado. A ver, vale, lo enviamos
de ahí y creo recordar que iba este.
Todos fallan,
no los no los encuentran la A ver, aquí
sí que teníamos que venir. A ver, eh,
paro esto.
Creo que era este de aquí.
Vale. Y aquí
por aquí podíamos ver origen destino.
Lo estuvimos viendo el otro día,
¿verdad? esto
que entrábamos de lleno en esto. O sea,
mira a ver,
me cargo esto, me cargo esto de aquí, lo
pongo en tiempo real y estas que sí
conservan sus direcciones IP dentro de
la red.
Vale, esto es perfecto. Vale, así que
funciona. Ahora le damos aquí,
¿vale? Y sería ver, bueno, este este de
aquí. Aquí sí que nos vale
eh lo enviamos de la 1.2 al 1.3. Sin
embargo, si os habéis fijado en cuando
lo hacemos desde una dirección que no
está dentro de la red,
no entiende lo que le estamos diciendo y
por lo tanto no sabe ni a dónde tiene
que llevar.
Vale, pues guay el ejercicio este,
Jorge,
que has configurado ahí todas las las
redes y todo eso. Ostras, eh, vemos,
empezamos con el otro, con el Claro que
nos como nos estamos colando en el
tiempo del otro. Vale, paro esta,
paro la clase esta y entramos con la
otra. M.